judd apatow is here i got me thinking
that got me thinking when judd apatow is
working on his computer and he drops it
on his foot
i wonder if people call him judd laptop
ow
now now I'm sorry I'm sorry you're right
that was just awful that was terrible
look I mean just that's awful give me
that give me that give me that this is a
piece of [ __ ] look at this we're gonna
strip you drop's on sometime what if
people call him Jud laptop out so stupid
let me just check this out here we gonna
make a phone call returns and exchanges
this is Britta Khan how may I assist you
yeah Bret I'd like to return a joke
please okay I'd be happy to help you
with that but would you mind taking a
brief customer quality surveys no I'm
actually kind of busy right now so no I
can't do that I'm sorry honey are you
late for your little league game little
league no I'm an adult I'm in the middle
of taping a television show oh I love TV
do you know the trivago gun no I don't
know the chavalla guy oh well maybe
you'll get to meet him one day when you
grow up and get famous I'm grown-up okay
now regarding the laughter your joke
received would you say it received not
enough laughter too much laughter or
just the right amount of laughter
definitely not enough laughter because
of your weird voice no I'll have you
know a lot of people like my voice
people with pet crows
can I please just return the joke you
know what I'm feeling some hostility
here so let me get my manager hold
please make your Good Friday a great
Friday with 30 percent off all Easter
jokes you'll be saying he is risen and I
is saving how can I help you yeah just
trying to return a joke that didn't work
okay sweetie now can you please hand the
phone to your mommy or your daddy you
know can I please just exchange the joke
I can do better I'm sending one of our
technicians out to fix your joke it
won't make it funnier but it will result
in a lot of cheap unearned applause you
know what frankly at this point I will
take that thank you very much happy to
help and tell judd apatow to be careful
with his computer otherwise he might
have a judge laptop oh that's classic
oh yeah you're funny wow that was
comically fast all right here we go
thank you
all right see I was good work fine yeah
take that then we got a great show
tonight Saidapet ass here you know he
directed funny people and co-created the
Netflix show love do you know what's not
funny people my love for these United
States of America
greatest country
[Applause]
but series mr. Jones Christian writers
here we go gets roses and Nicky Romero
be right back
you
you